[Music]
it still feels surreal right now like
i'm still trying to
keep my emotions intact but
you know this is amazing feeling right
now just be ready big things coming
big things coming man
don't forget the hat
i'm official now
[Music]
i like how le'veon bell was talking to
the camera while he was flipping through
the contract as if he was reading it
yeah well like you know like oh i got
left hanging i'll be right back i got to
read this page just sign the thing and
move on your agent took care of all that
for you but le'veon bell now officially
a member of the new york jets jumping
from the steelers we're going to do some
free agency prop bets now we're going to
start with le'veon bell he's had a year
off from football if you haven't heard
he will be a key ingredient in the jets
offense over under for total yards from
scrimmage for le'veon bell
1800 big cat you're going over you're
going under
that's a stupid question you always go
over
no i might go under here i don't know
how to like the guy took a year off of
football i think it's a very
weird and unique case here where we
don't know what a guy who takes a year
off in his prime not because of injury
just because a year off because of the
contract situation i'd lean under here
i'm going to go under with this one
because who's to say that halfway
through the season he doesn't want to
take the rest of the season off to wait
for his next contract
i'll go under for other reasons i mean
you've got the injury factor and how
many times do we see a guy who hasn't
played football in a long time he gets
banged up and you know you got to get
that callus back on as as jim harbaugh
would say and maybe the callus is gone
and it's going to take him a while to
really get back to the kind of guy that
he was what kind of offensive line are
the jets going to have i know they
traded for collegio assembly but you
know the steelers who had a very bad
offensive line last decade and somehow
won two super bowls with a very bad
offensive line they've had a great
offensive line in recent years under
mike munchek the offensive line coach
who has since left for denver that has
helped le'veon bell you know it's easy
to have patience and pick your spot when
you aren't being swarmed by defenders
and that's that's where the offensive
line comes in so i'm going to agree with
you on this i mean we're caught up in
what le'veon bell could do with sam
darnold but 1800 is a high bar and i
don't think he's gonna make it maybe
next year but not this year and one last
point to add on i mean le'veon bell
let's remember that he always had some
little nagging leg issues you know that
happened a couple of years in a row
there with the steelers so do you want
to bet that he's going to play all 16
games i wouldn't make that bet
yeah and you also have to assume that
sam darnold is going to be able to take
advantage of whatever le'veon bell can
do if darnold can't get the ball down
the field that that gives defenses even
more reason to stack up and stop le'veon
bell all right odell beckham jr gone
from new york enters the cleveland
browns over under on receiving yards for
beckham this year eleven hundred i'm
taking the over on this one this one the
browns are gonna be one of the most
explosive offenses in the nfl odell
beckham what is what is odell beckham's
number one threat that slant route baker
mayfield throws it very very well i
think they're going to be explosive all
year long i think with the other weapons
that they have in david ninjoku and
jarvis landry i think it's going to be
hard to just focus on odell beckham and
like let's just think about what del
beckham's coming from the new york
giants where there weren't a lot of
weapons and you had an old eli manning
throwing to you to now a young guy who
can extend plays and other weapons
around you i think his life is going to
be easier i think he's going to have
more than 1100 yards
and then he got nick chubb at tailback
who's done a great job for them in his
rookie year kareem hunt at some point we
assume in 2019 will be cleared to play
that's just even more reason to soften
up a defense if you have guys banging it
between the tackles and gaining yards so
i think the browns can have an explosive
offense and otto beckham jr is is going
to i agree with you be over 1100 yards
let's stay with cleveland baker mayfield
he had i think he tied the record for
single season touchdown passes for a
rookie last year
he broke through he broke the record he
was close to it at the end of the year
and he did indeed break it baker
mayfield this year over under 29.5
touchdown passes what do you got this is
the easiest over in the world i can't
who set this line did you set this line
florio
no i never set the lines it's a real
line it's a real line so get your money
it's a real line yes oh wow okay yeah
this is the easiest over i'm thinking
he's gonna have i don't know 35 would 40
shock you
40 wouldn't shock me nothing's going to
shock me out of this guy the guy's
special and now you've given him one of
the best receivers that the nfl has seen
in the last 20 years
i think of course he's going to sail
over 29-5
yeah if he doesn't if he plays all 16
games i would be shocked if he didn't if
he didn't get in the high 30s here next
year
you came dangerously close to applying
the jinx do not apply the jinx to baker
mayfield you said if he plays all 16
games why wouldn't he play all 16 games
you're so stupid you can't jinx these
things come on we're just two guys
talking
you're trying to you're trying to get
ahead of it now you don't want the
browns fans loading up your twitter
mentions saying you've jinxed baker
mayfield fans don't do this you not now
now that you've jinxed baker if he plays
16 games you're implying he may get
injured antonio brown
his pass catches for the oakland raiders
now that he's got a new team the over
under is 95 5. i know where i'm going on
this one i wanna hear what you have to
say over easily because you don't trade
for antonio brown and not get him the
ball and you also don't keep antonio
brown happy if you don't get him the
ball constantly i feel like the entire
offense is gonna run through antonio
brown to keep him happy because what was
this move this was a move to have a star
for las vegas when they make that move
soon in the next couple years antonio
brown's got to be happy he's got to feel
like he's the center of the offense he
is going to have a hundred and
seven catches this year
all right write that down and let's
alert our friends at old takes exposed
about this one because the one
ingredient that you are overlooking and
we haven't had you on your show this
week to talk about the aftermath of this
trade and you apparently haven't
listened to the show either so thank you
for that because you know my opinion on
this if you had
derek carr is the wild card in all this
and i don't believe that derek carr is
going to be able to accurately place the
ball the way that antonio brown is used
to getting it from ben roethlisberger
and i think that derek carr is going to
cause this whole thing to blow up and
this is step one toward getting everyone
on board with the idea that derek carr
isn't the answer and by next year and
maybe by next year it will be 107
because they have a different
quarterback when they go to las vegas
but this year if it's derek carr as the
quarterback antonio brown's not getting
to 95 catches quite an assumption by you
to assume that derek carr will be the
quarterback this year who's to say oh oh
you're you're oh you're you're going
you're going next level beyond the next
level with that one they have three
picks in the first round mike that feels
like a lot of stuff if they like a
certain quarterback if they like a
certain five eight quarterback a little
bit more than everyone else hmm
five eight and 220 pound kyler murray
and i know that there are reports out
there that john grunder really likes him
i don't know if he has the patience to
work with a rookie quarterback that's
been part of his reputation for the last
20 years he likes older guys he likes
more experienced guys he likes guys who
get it and understand how it works at
the nfl level but yeah you know what if
if i guess that's i'd want to wait and
see what happens after the draft before
putting my money down on the over under
for antonio brown because if it is derek
carr i'm taking the enter because
there's no way derek carr is completing
95 plus passes to antonio brown this
year stats will you please put that in
the book that i just moved mike florio
off his position it's only 7 43 in the
morning we're in the first hour and i've
already got him off one of his positions
you yeah you usually it takes you an
hour to warm up so i'm impressed that
you got yeah i'm i'm i'm bracing for the
onslaught in hour three and now you got
me uh in the second hour of the radio
side first hour of the tv side that
always confuses me desean jackson back
in philadelphia with carson wentz the
band is kind of back together but he's
never played with wence before the over
under for desean jackson receiving yards
is a mere 900.
i will i'll take over here i i think
carson wentz has probably had a lot of
humble pie this past year you know
obviously they win a super bowl with
nick foles he comes back he's not great
and then all of the uh talk about him
not being a great teammate and the
anonymous sources i think he's going to
spread the ball around because you we
saw it last year carson wentz when he
was playing it was basically zachary
zachary zack ertz so i think he will
spread the ball around i think with al
shawn jeffrey still there and desean
jackson spreading you know she's
stretching the field the philly offense
is going to be dynamic i will take the
over for desean jackson 900 yards
yeah i agree with you as well the guy's
got like 28 touchdown receptions in his
career of 50 yards or longer it's a lot
easier to get to 900 when you're gaining
yards in big chunks like that and he can
still run behind defenses and he's you
know we have to kind of like this weird
sense the eagles weren't very good last
year they made it to the final eight
they got it together and if wence can
stay healthy and that's not a jinx
if eagles fans that's reality that
you've lived the last two years if he
can stay healthy they can be very
special this year all right this is one
i've been holding just for you nick
foles jacksonville touchdown passes over
under 21-5
that's a good line
that's a good line and i don't i
honestly
i'll take over just because of the
league and how it's all set up and and
you know quarterback it's a
quarterback's league i don't know if
anyone's told you that mike i just took
you to school i haven't heard that yeah
thank you
i'll take the over there although i'm
not i'm not super sold on nick foles in
jacksonville i think i think nick foles
you know the run that he made in the
playoffs in the super bowl run was
unbelievable
i think doug peterson and nick foles
together is a dynamic you know duo i
think nick foles without doug peterson
has been a different guy and we've seen
nick foles a lot like he started for an
entire year you know that chip kelly
year where they went on from him and he
had what two interceptions that entire
year i think nick foles is good not
great i'll take the over but if you set
it at
27 i'd go under
one key factor in all of this and we're
gonna be talking more about foal's next
segment will john d filippo who's
getting another chance to be an
offensive coordinator will he be trying
to sell himself as a head coach like he
did in minnesota last year and skew too
much toward the pass or will he
incorporate leonard fernett run the ball
that could cut down on the touchdown
passes but it could make it more likely
that this will work as a team in
jacksonville all right last one which
player on a new team has the highest
selling jersey in
2019
oh
i'm gonna go antonio brown raiders
because i think any raiders jersey
i mean the raiders jerseys are the
classic look the silver and black i you
know you have the crossover with raiders
jerseys we're not even you know if
you're a raiders fan even if you're not
a raiders fan that's a cool jersey to
own i'm going to say antonio brown
oakland raiders
and you know i like that one because who
else are you going to get a jersey for
on the oakland raiders all due respect
but but odell beckham
how do you not want that brown and
orange with beckham and 13 on it how do
you not want that jersey because you
just said it you just you just proved it
baker mayfield will eat into that that's
exactly what's going to happen yeah i
but i just think a lot of people are
going to be buying browns jerseys
because there's probably a lot of
closets out there see the shining sea
that don't have browns jerseys in them a
lot more closets have raider jerseys in
them so you know what i've been waiting
for 30 years to buy a browns jersey now
is the time to get one i'll go get odell
beckham
i think that's going to be the attitude
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports